c'était en 2003 jean charest est en
campagne pour devenir premier ministre
il présente son candidat dans louis
hébert à québec depuis sam hamad
ingénieur et jusqu'à récemment vice
président de la firme de génie conseil
roche
qu'il s'agisse de raymond garneau de
marc yvan côté de parti libéral du
québec a toujours pu compter sur une
équipe forte
au fond de la salle il est là marc yvan
côté ses côtés c'est un ami on travaille
à la même firme d'ingénierie déjà cette
époque
marc yvan côté avait contribué à
implanter un système de financement
politique chez roche
sam hamad a souvent dû se défendre là
dessus j'ai toujours respecté la loi
personne ne m'a demandé de donner mais
peut-il ne pas avoir été au courant des
méthodes de marc yvan côté nous vous
dévoilons ce soir des courriels qui
montre que marc yvan côté s'activaient
pour le financement politique de sam
hamad le ministre était pour sa part une
source d'informations stratégiques et
faisait avancer ces dossiers au
gouvernement au point on l'appelait
l'entreprise premier tech est un fleuron
économique du bas saint laurent et même
du québec spécialisée en produits
d'horticulture en équipement industriel
et en technologies environnementales
premier tech à plus de 3200 employés
dans 24 pays
au fil des années l'entreprise a reçu
des dizaines de millions de subventions
des deux gouvernements pour comprendre
ce qui suit il faut connaître les
personnes d'influencé dans l'entreprise
jean bélanger président et chef de
l'exploitation il goudreau vice
président développement corporatif
il est inscrit au registre des
lobbyistes pour premier tech
mais celui qui n'est pas inscrit comme
lobbyiste et qu'ils aient un accès
encore plus privilégié et plus secrets
au pouvoir c'est marc yvan côté rachat
de libercourt nations du québec m'a pris
marc yvan côté c'est un vieux routier en
politiques sur la scène fédérale
il a été entachée par le scandale des
commandites l'un des premiers gestes là
paul martin aujourd'hui est donc été de
bannir dix membres du parti libéral du
canada de les exclure à vis de la
famille libérale et parmi eux marc yvan
côté d'ancien ministre provincial de
robert bourassa de daniel johnson
bonjour notre côté on joue
il a aussi dû s'expliquer à la
commission charbonneau
comment un séminaire à côté de vous
opposer geste illégal et vous laisser
faire je vous avez trompés si oui
et malgré la controverse qui le suit
marc yvan côté était jusqu'à son
arrestation il ya deux semaines vice
président du conseil d'administration de
premier tech
il présidait même le comité de
gouvernance de l'entreprise monsieur sam
hamad
enfin sam hamad il a été élu en 2003 et
a presque toujours siégé au conseil des
ministres en 2010 premier tech vais
t'acheter un concurrent et demande
l'aide investissement québec les
courriels que nous avons tenu d'un accès
inédit aux tractations en coulisses
sam hamad aurait poussé très fort et
même donner des informations sur les
délibérations du conseil du trésor
pourtant confidentielles
courriel du goudron à marc yvan côté et
jean bélanger la madame du trésor
nippone facile dans cet amphithéâtre est
difficile il n'a pas plié même avec la
pression de certains proches de premier
tech
la madame du trésor c'est la ministre
michelle courchesne
la solution ultime doit être fait
monsieur charest lorsqu'on analyse les
comportements du président
d'investissement québec et de la madame
ou trésor il n'ya pas d'autre choix que
tu en penses tu marqueras marc yvan côté
propose la solution
sam hamad georges rappelle que ça m'a
offert son aide pour convaincre le
trésor
sam siège au trésor ce qui n'est pas le
cas de tous les ministres et selon les
courriels sam hamad s'offrent même pour
intervenir auprès des dirigeants
d'investissement québec
j'attends d'ici la fin de la journée le
retour de sam key falra daou et
peut-être à bazas et dès le lendemain
marc yvan côté à de l'information
toujours de son ami sam hamad
mon ami viennent faire rapport sur les
deux téléphones fait ce jour même il a
d'abord parlé adaou deuxième téléphone a
été fait à gignac
sa maman aurait donc appelé directement
son collègue clément gignac ministre du
développement économique pour parler du
dossier de premier tech et la fin du
courriel laisse songeur cette démarche
est secret ps je l'envoie qu'à toi afin
de protéger notre ami on a brisé la loi
en matière de lobbying au québec et je
pense que le commissaire au lobbyisme
serait tout à fait justifiée
d'investiguer cette affaire plus en
détail
denis saint martin et professeur au
département des sciences politiques à
l'université de montréal
nous lui avons montré les courriels et
la chose qui est la plus grave est que
les courriels les 130 que monsieur côté
et les dirigeants de la firme premier
tech et être en possession
d'informations privilégiées concernant
l'état des discussions ministérielles
entourant le projet de soutien à cette
entreprise
en janvier 2011 c'est au tour d'un
attaché politique de sam hamad de
solliciter marc yvan côté pour un
cocktail de financement dans cet hôtel
de québec
ils accèdent ensuite les courriels
indique que sam hamad continuent
d'informer marc yvan côté sur ses
démarches auprès d'investissement québec
nos premiers à face ils téléphonent en
après midi
notre ami lui a fait part que c'était le
souhait du gouvernement que ce dossier
se réalise il semble que le message
était assez ferme
premier tech abandonne finalement son
projet d'acheter une autre entreprise
le 7 septembre 2011
sam hamad obtient ministère encore plus
stratégique pour premier tech qui a
encore besoin de lui je remplirai les
devoirs de ma charge de ministre
développement économique
premier tech revient à la charge avec
une autre demande de prêt à
investissement québec et une subvention
qui dépend directement du ministère de
sam hamad
deux mois après la demande les choses
semblent aller rondement
le ministre vient vers la fin de semaine
et à part le mardi 17 janvier pour davos
deux semaines
l'analyse est temps qu il n'y a pas de
problématique pour l'instant je suis en
contact avec sa secrétaire pour le voir
avant son départ
deux mois et demi plus tard ça y est
premier tech reçoit sa promesse de
subventions et de prêts mais elle veut
un plus gros montant marc yvan côté
écrit à ses collègues qu'il va
entreprendre la démarche
moins d'une semaine plus tard marc yvan
côté des jeunes avec sam hamad
après cette rencontre il écrit à jean
bélanger j'ai rencontré à 7h ce matin
notre ami pour faire le point je vais
tenter de te rejoindre plus tard afin de
te transmettre l'état de situation je
souhaite le faire sur un téléphone
régulier l'homme moi je dirais le
ministre hamad n'a pas été plus d'un
parce qu'il ne peut pas construire les
pare-feu suffisant pour le couper de ses
anciennes accointances privé et il s'est
placé en situation de conflit d'intérêts
et là je pense que le commissaire à
l'éthique d'assemblée nationale et
serait tout à fait justifiée de regarder
à cette affaire
le lendemain du déjeuner entre marc yvan
côté et sam hamad
l'affairé est dans le sac son chef de
cabinet adjoint donne des nouvelles
on a travaillé fort vous aurez des
nouvelles bientôt via le canal régulier
positif négatif on partait de loin mais
on a travaillé fort pour ne pas avoir le
statut cour le 7 mai tambours trompettes
et caméras jean charest est à rivière du
loup pour annoncer le près de 11
millions de dollars
il y a aussi une subvention de plus de 8
millions du ministère de sam hamad
développement économique
le fédéral injecte 16 millions et
premier tech 75 millions secret de sa
nouveaux emplois
un objectif qui sera même dépassé selon
l'entreprise
en réponse à nos questions le président
de premier tech jean bélanger a reconnu
que marc yvan côté aurait dû
s'enregistrer comme lobbyiste il a
quitté l'entreprise à la suite de son
arrestation et le financement politique
dans tout ça la policiers traitent la r2
premier tech et sa femme un état que sur
le congé des ministres à gien c'est
aucune aucune contribution pour les
aiglons mais les courriels disent autre
chose dès 2008 pour la soirée de
financement de sam
est-ce qu'on a souscrit car j'ai pas eu
de demande pour le cocktail san il faut
faire une contribution significative
j'ai l'intention m'a parlé avec monsieur
bélanger demain parfait pour ça il faut
faire quelque chose de significatif
selon notre compilation certains
dirigeants administrateurs de premier
tech et des membres de leur famille ont
donné plus de 20 mille dollars au parti
libéral du québec de 2008 à 2012
certains ont fait un don dans le comté
de sam hamad
même s'ils n'habitent pas dans sa
circonscription marc yvan côté sa
famille ont pour leur part donné plus de
17000 $ au parti libéral dans les mêmes
années
premier tech nous a fait valoir que les
contributions de ses dirigeants et de
leurs familles étaient marginales légale
et que l'entreprise ignore tout des
contributions faites par marc yvan côté
sa famille
alors retour en 2003 dès ses débuts en
politique les journalistes questionner
déjà sam hamad sur sa relation avec marc
yvan comptait treize ans plus tard nous
lui avons posé des questions encore plus
précis sur cette relation
son attaché de presse s'est contenté
nous dire que le ministre avait déjà
répondu à toutes les questions
marc yvan côté il ne nous a pas rappelés
pour effet de tout j'ai ramassé des
sourds effets de l'organisation
politique et g 10 jean charest de
m'utiliser là où je serai le plus utile
plus d'orge pour réduire de me cacher
pour le parti il n'était pas question de
cacher marc yvan côté à l'époque même si
déjà sa présence suscitait des questions
qui se sont avérées prémonitoire
marc yvan côté nous a donné un peu mais
la campagne de 80 qui va encore nous
donner un coup de main la campagne de
2003 la présence de mark iv le cpo c'est
quelque chose de très positif
puis je suis très heureux de l'avoir
dans notre équipe
je vois souris vous voyez pour gagner
l'or aux billets dessous